[Musique]
bonjour ils vont pas quittes
bonjour bonjour aux auditeurs de l'un
des onze candidats aux sénatoriales du
24 septembre ce matin dans son caddie
candidats quoi ils vont pas quitte
candidats au gré système candidats
dissidence ppm candidat divers gauche
candidat libre et divers gauche candidat
d'ouverture puisque je considère
aujourd'hui qu'il faut véritablement
faire taire les querelles subalternes
n'est ce pas qui pollue le débat
politique c'est vous qui est à l'origine
de ces querelles maj paquito sein de
votre formation le parti tu assistes
martiniquais pas du tout vous avez bien
j'ai bien expliqué le sens de ma
démarche et j'ai contesté
zodiac candidat à la candidature il
poserait perdu et vous n'avez pas aimé
ça non je n'ai pas perdu j'ai tout
simplement côté c'est une procédure qui
n'a pas respecté les règles
vous savez j'ai une image parti
progressiste martiniquais c'est celui
qui le plus respectueux des règles je le
pouvais depuis déjà très longtemps après
avoir constaté que les bleus n'avaient
pas été respectées j'ai pris la décision
de me présenter en toute liberté
la vague est allé mardi la main tendue
hier catherine conconne la candidate
officielle
pm and is est que quand on ne la joue
pas collectif qu'on ne respecte pas les
règles eh bien on démissionne
il faut avoir sous-entendu le courage de
démissionner bettman en voudra je suis
assez sûr bruits de tondeuses adel je ne
dis pas davantage en tout cas maintenant
inscrit concert surprise en ce qui
concerne le respect des règles elle
n'est pas un exemple je peux vous
expliquer vraiment dire par là ça des
goussets du parti et elle est très
claire de non cumul des mandats il a été
demandé à tous les membres du parti de
se contenter de dieu mandat il me semble
qu'elle n'a pas respecté cette règle
afin de dire qu'elle démissionne je
pense qu'il faut qu'elles s'impliquent
et le n'est pas la seule serait le seul
dont l une des rares à ne pas avoir
respecté cette règle essentielle de non
cumul
vous avez l'intention de démissionner du
parti progressiste martiniquais
aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse c'est
véritablement ma dimanche au service de
l'intérêt
de la mythique je pense que c'est ça
l'essentiel nous vivons après nous
verrons a pris avec le parti oui ce qui
va se passer en tout cas beaucoup
pensent au sein du parti de traînel et
même dans d'autres formations politiques
que si ils vont pas qui tu agis ainsi
aujourd'hui c'est que quelque part il a
quand même la valve de serge letchimy
non je n'en sais rien je pense qu'il
faudrait lui poser la question
il a dit non il ne lui a posé la
question ici direct guam et donc parce
que sa question et la réponse est la
bonne réponse
non ce qu'il faut quand même dit qu'ils
avaient défié serge letchimy dons parce
que le courant et c'est précisément là
dimanche que j'ai engagé c'est à lui que
je me présente devant les électeurs et
les martiniquais et les martiniquais
avec un projet avec un discours et avec
véritablement avec véritablement la
volonté de service et ça l'a dit aux
grands électeurs que vous rencontrez
absolument et je précise aussi que
depuis déjà assez longtemps depuis plus
de 20 ans ils me connaissent et j'ai
montré n'est ce pas ma volonté de servir
l'intérêt général sur tous les services
publics locaux
il faut pas qu'ils sont ils aussi bien
ici qu'ailleurs fait partie de cette
catégorie d'hommes politiques estiment
que le temps qui passe à avoir milité
doit être récompensé nécessairement par
un poste face à lui deux touches plein
de tout j'ai souvent dit n'est ce pas
que mon objectif ce n'est pas une
récompense
c'est une tâche au service de l'intérêt
général
je n'ai jamais considéré comme mandat
était la récompense du travail effectué
et le temps qui passe c'est tout
simplement le temps qui m'a permis
d'accumuler de l'expérience et me mettre
en situation aujourd'hui de servir corps
de manière plus pertinente les intérêts
de notre pays c'est ça l'essentiel
ils vont pas qui tu es mûr pour la
fonction de ce que vous dit absolument
nouveau la fonction surtout non pas au
goût politique m'ont conduit tout
naturellement à cette fonction de
sénateur c'est quand le sénat l'une des
missions essentielles du sénat comme
vous le savez c'est la représentation
des collectivités locales les services
publics locaux
de quoi me suis occupé depuis déjà plus
de 20 ans les services publics locaux
je m'occupe de lo gerbo couple l
assainissement et je m'occupe du
traitement des déchets qu'est ce qui
n'est pas plus quotidiens
que la gestion des déchets la gestion de
la santé ce sont trois missions qui
m'ont été confiés depuis déjà 95 par
aimé césaire lui-même et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je défends c'est toi
mission aussi bien avoir dit nick qu'au
niveau de l'hexagone
parce que vous savez très bien que les
questions concernant la santé les
décisions importantes concernant la
santé ne se prennent pas essentiellement
avant dit nik c'est pour cette raison
d'ailleurs sur cette question de la
santé quel serait le dossier prioritaire
que vous porteriez le dossier
prioritaire c'est généralement du cancer
de la prostate par exemple la série clio
chlordécone
il ya beaucoup de pathologies
véritablement à nos gènes on le sait les
pertes matérielles les problèmes de
niveau le degré les problèmes il faut le
dire il y en a beaucoup d'avc il ya
beaucoup de pathologies le concert
également le cancer de la prostate
il ya beaucoup de pathologies qui sont
véritablement propre à notre pays et à
la date d'aujourd'hui
à la date d'aujourd'hui l'organisation
et les moyens dont dispose le mode
hospitalier ne sont pas à la hauteur des
enjeux sanitaires
il faut par conséquent tout le monde se
mobilise c'est véritablement l'appel que
je n'ose il faut que tous les élus de
quelques bogues ils se trouvent sur
mobilisent pour véritablement faire
avancer ce dossier des moyens ils sont
bien là dix semaines justement
concernant les foyens justement
concernant les moyens mis à la
disposition du système de la santé en
martinique
ceux qui savent et qui travaille au chu
ceux qui établissent des rapports la
demande parfois des ministères disent
jamais eu tel établissement n'a reçu
autant d'argent mais seulement il n'est
pas bien utilisé
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez faire et
dire là dessus le discours que je tiens
depuis déjà des années je pense qu'il
aboutira c'est le modèle qui n'est pas
adapté
le modèle l'organisation du système
hospitalier et martinique est tout
simplement la réplique du modèle qui est
en vigueur dans l'hexagone n'est pas
adaptée aux enjeux n'est pas adapté avec
ses techniciens technocrates qui dessine
avec des traits de crayon thriller
modèle économique date le nôtre ici nous
pourrions être beaucoup plus efficace un
adapte le modèle c'est vrai pour la
santé comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines
il ne suffit pas de plaquer à
l'identique des modèles qui ne sont même
pas aujourd'hui performant au niveau
l'hexagone je vous donne un exemple très
simple un copain confiant qui s'appelle
coefficient géographique et qui permet
de mesurer véritablement les surcoûts
les secours auquel le monde hospitalier
est actuellement confronté sans
provision aujourd'hui est à 26 % des
eaux 27 pouces
il vient d'être augmentée il est
augmentée d'un pouce à tous les calculs
tous les calculs faits aussi bien ici
qu'ailleurs montre le kobo équilibrer le
système hospitalier
il faudrait que ces conditions tourne
autour de 37 pouces je me bats
d'ailleurs depuis des années pour faire
entendre ce discours nous avons tenu un
point son passé de 26 à 27
et c'est l'un des exemples il y en a
beaucoup d'autres
le u saute hospitalier université de la
martinique dont j'assure la présidence
et les sens je pose la question est bien
le i
nous n'avons pas les moyens de mettre en
oeuvre la dimension universitaire du ch
et de la martinique le plus petit chu de
fès et poitiers qui a pratiquement plus
de dix fois plus le professeur renaud
donc vous voyez il ya toute une série
d'éléments jours de congés de l'argent
par la fenêtre avec l'argent est mal
utilisé la santé en martinique
pourquoi ne pas prendre la décision ne
sais pas moi qui ai pas de huées en
martinique alors pas du tout une chu
exerceront appelle les fonctions de
nouveaux dégâts les hôpitaux de
proximité et pour toutes les pathologies
de temps à parler on s'adresse au chu
pour ne pas avoir à prendre un billet
d'avion catastrophe quand on a le temps
et les moyens de le faire pour aller se
faire soigner ailleurs le 1 signifie chu
à des missions de recours des fonctions
de recours aux avait une grosse heure
une maladie extrêmement importante vous
adresser à chercher de la moitié comme
d'ailleurs chu de n'importe quel et jean
de fos et vous êtes en droit d'attendre
ces jobs de prestations donc nous sommes
dans un ensemble dans un ensemble
dans un pays de soule l'ensemble du
territoire et nous sommes en droit
d'attendre des prestations tout à fait
équivalent et ce message est entendu
auprès des grands électeurs rencontrés
oui ce message ait été entendu pascal et
man 10 gordini quai à la date
d'aujourd'hui ont véritablement compris
qu'il ya là un enjeu essentiel et vous
savez je dis souvent qu'il n'ya pas de
santé de droite de gauche ou du centre
il faut nécessairement qui viennent
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
martiniquais pour véritablement adapter
le modèle hospitalier aux véritables
enjeux auxquels notre pays se trouve
aujourd'hui confronté merci ils vont pas
qui tempère nous être l'un des onze
candidats en lice pour ces sénateurs a
dominé cette bonne journée
merci beaucoup
[Musique]